[Música]
[Aplausos]
em frutas e verduras no seu prato sem
mas sei que a coxinha tá na tua mente
mas não pode comer pra não ficar gordo
ou amigo comigo história diferente
quando o assunto é rodízio eu sou o pior
cliente cassol se desespera quando eu
chegou eu sei que eu deveria estar na
academia mais bloquear deitados
assistindo netflix e contudo pega os
pesados
não vou mudar meu corpo não foi assim
que deus me criou e diesel não quero ser
o que eu amo ser gostoso
por mais que achei que eu tô karen ice
ano isto g
eu e maior estado no peru alguém
enquanto o meu sempre foi boca foi feita
baku neto mais que ache que eu tô nem aí
sim eu gosto checher meu lema é tabu no
bem alguém enquanto meu sempre foi boca
foi feita pra cumê
com isso a visão escreve deixou
[Música]
eu sei que eu deveria estar na academia
mais tô aqui deitado o assistindo
netflix enquanto pega os pesados
não vou mudar meu corpo não foi assim
que deus me criou 20 dizendo eu quero
ser porque angolano chegou tô com mais
que ache que eu tô que tô nem aí se é
visto g1
o tema é pato não tem nogueira enquanto
meu sempre foi o boca foi feita pouco
tempo mas que achei que ia tomrh nem se
eles o chefe é o meu lema é tabu no pino
gay enquanto meu sempre foi boca foi
feita pacu ver tudo mas que acham que eu
tô que tô nem aí se é visto chez o tema
é tabu no pino gay enquanto meu sempre
foi boca foi feita baku e tudo mais que
ache que é top
tô nem aí se ambos do chef é seu tema é
alto no peru alguém enquanto meu sempre
foi o boca foi feita pacu mê
ei eu terei
e é isso aí foi mais uma paródia se você
tiver gostar desse identificado não
esquece e clicar em gostei tá eu quero
que você comente aqui embaixo uma música
pra gente fazer paródia e não se esqueça
de se inscrever no canal que participou
dessa paróquia foi ele mesmo em caio
oliveira ó se você clicar aqui e você
vai se inscrever no canal dele conhecer
o trabalho dele e é nós não esqueça você
quer fazer sua paródia você quer fazer é
seu clipe musical não ser que se você
tem vontade de fazer produzir um
comercial é um rapaz que trabalha como
paródia todas essas qualidades que você
vê nas ruas padre joão vilas ine
o e mail deles aqui na descrição do
vídeo pra você quiser trabalhar com
francine ele está dando tchau e na
frente da câmera o passo eu a ele mesmo
a gravar ou quer gravar o áudio para
fazer uma música quero fazer um ip
as pessoas que fazem a minha voz é a
galera humorista em maurício tamo junto
e mail dele está aqui embaixo você
quiser fazer a sua paródia à sua música
o seu clipe
não sei se é com você então tamo junto é
nós e mostra seus amigos que gosta de
comer tamo junto
olha tem itália deve entrar